Hey, Okay.
Don't hurt nobody.
Hey. That's a great skip.
- Thank you.
- Yeah.
Kind of want
to bring that back.
You should.
I'm okay with that.
I'm already tired
of, like, dabbing,
- but I like to--
- Ooh! It's perfect.
Oh, my God.
Who would throw this out?
An idiot.
This is an original
Gi'gel cocktail-slash-lounge
ottoman. It's priceless.
Oh, really?
it's priceless?
- Yeah, $75.
- Okay.
Not including shipping.
Well, we got to get it.
This is perfect.
I can see me writing
my very first novel
on this baby.
Hey. I can see me now.
What can you see?
Me in the mirror
across the street.
You see it?
What up, playboy?
All right, come on, Paul.
Bring the ottoman.
Bring it.
♪♪ [theme]
I lost that dog
immediately.
Wow. How many days
did you have him?
- One.
- Oh.
Man: You should have
told me, Henrietta!
You should have told me!
You should have
told me, Henrietta!
Ooh, you done done it
now, Henrietta.
No, wait. You shouldn't
have told me, Henrietta.
Old lyin'-ass Henrietta.
Henrietta, why?
[chuckling]
You want me to call
Henrietta for you, baby?
- Because I'll call her.
- Laugh it up.
But I am preparing
for one
of three auditions
that I have today.
Oh, excuse me.
Congratulations,
Mr. Magic over here.
What is that?
This original Gi'gel
cocktail-slash-lounge ottoman
was bestowed upon us
by fate.
Yes. We found it
across the street.
What, you brought
streetware into this house?
Come on, Mo. It's nice.
That thing's probably
riddled with needles.
There were only two
needles in it.
Stop. [chuckle]
Mo, he's kidding.
He's playing.
He's just kidding.
You know what?
I can't deal with this
right now.
I have to get ready.
Hey, Mo.
Do you have Henrietta's
number in there,
- or are you just--
- Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha!
I'm on fire.
I'm so on it today.
I'm sorry.
I couldn't hear you
because I'm too busy
making strides
towards my dream.
What are you two doing?
We're going to be
setting up the ottoman.
- You feel me.
- Set it up, then!
We will.
No, Ma, this is
a feature film.
No, no, no.
I did student films
in college.
Yeah, this is just
the audition.
My manager, he said
I have a really good shot
at this one, so--
Yeah.
Hey, Ma, I'm going to call
you right back, all right?
Hi. Uh--
Hi. Back of the line.
Oh, no, no, no. See, I'm
not here to be an extra.
Sorry, man. No, I'm here
to audition
for the role of Lucas.
Oh, you and everyone else.
Back of the line.
It's that way.
All right, so if you
have questions--
Okay. Uh. Sorry.
One more time. Excuse me.
Hey. Yeah. See, I have
another audition at 3.
Ooh! Golly me, you have
another audition.
- Yeah.
- Let me get right on
accommodating you
for that.
Oh. Hello?
Show business?
We got a guy. He's coming
in for an audition.
- Oh, you totally--
- So just drop everything.
- Okay, okay.
- I'm going to bring him
in for his audition.
- I see what you did there.
- All right,
back of the line.
Okay. Going to be
in the back.
Both:
Rock, paper, scissors, shoot.
All right,
keep it coming.
Both:
Rock, paper, scissors, shoot.
- Okay.
One more time.
This is it.
Okay.
Rock, paper, scissors, shoot.
Okay, so obviously
we're both going to keep
choosing paper.
How about
I just go first?
Um, no. How about
I use it first?
All right. Let me just
throw something out there.
How about I use
the ottoman first?
Idea. And I'm
spitballing here.
- Okay. I'm gonna go with you.
- Walk with me.
I'll use it first.
You can use it after.
Hmm. Allow me
to share with you
- a tale from my past.
- Okay.
When I was a young child,
my grandmother,
who is now dead,
said to me, "Miloh,
first is the worst."
And I remember that
so vividly,
and I can hear it
in my head.
Bringing in your dead
grandma. All right.
- And I remember--
- You got it, you got it.
You win.
And I want to bear
that burden, Paul.
I don't want that on you.
I don't want you to have
that negative energy.
I do it for you, Paul.
I do it for you.
[sighs]
[sniffing]
Hey, if I make cookies,
would you have some?
Yeah.
Okay. So I'm thinking
how about I make
maple bacon brown sugar
cookies, all right?
Mm. Sounds good.
Do you think I eat
too much sugar?
I don't want to
die of betes.
Hi. How are you guys doing?
Can you state your name
for the camera, please?
Yeah, sure. Uh, ahem.
Hi. I'm--
Actually, I'm going
to stop you there.
Uh, we-- I need
to fix this lighting.
Carl, do you have a light?
Can we get a light in for him?
Do we have any extra
lights we can bring in?
Can we get a light?
Can we get, like, a--
like, two or three lights?
Can we get
some lights for this--
- Hey, Paul.
- What's up, girl?
Hey, um,
so I have some--
some spider bites.
- And I--
- And?
And I think that they
may or may not have
come from--
from the ottoman,
from Gi'gel.
Miloh. Miloh, Miloh.
Spiders are everywhere
in L.A.
You probably got one
from outside, silly.
I'll tell you what.
I'll take my turn
with the ottoman,
and if I get bit,
we'll cross that bridge
when we get there.
- All right?
- Okay.
Just--
Just be careful, Paul.
All right? Spider bites
can be really dangerous.
Girl, danger is
my middle name, okay?
I'm joking. It's Philip.
Miloh?
No, you scheduled these
too close together, man.
No, I'm
at the third one now.
I didn't go
to the second one!
I didn't go to the second one
because I was at the first
one for three hours.
And when I finally
got in the room,
they took 15 minutes
to set up a light
because nobody's prepared to
light a black man in America.
Uh, excuse me.
I'm sorry to interrupt.
I don't have your
audition fee of $60.
Uh, audition fee?
- $60.
- Yes.
One second, please.
Bruh! An audition fee?
Come on, man.
Hello?
Hey, Paul?
Paul?
Gi'gel?
Hey. What's wrong?
We got any beer?
Yeah, but, Mo,
what's wrong?
Mo. Ohh!
What?
Oh! Oh! What happened
to your face?
Sick, right?
I think I had an allergic
reaction to my sandwich.
- What?
- Yeah.
Paul, those are spider bites.
No.
And where could he have
possibly gotten spider bites?
Please tell me it's from
this upholstered gutter trash
that you two insisted
on bringing in here.
I swear to God, man.
Get rid of that thing.
I'm serious.
[door closes]
- Man.
- I think it's cute.
Hey, Paul.
- Hey. Hey.
- Hey.
Hey, don't move
for, like, two seconds.
- Okay.
- Watch what I do.
Just don't move, okay?
What the hell was that?
You said don't move.
I trusted you.
I know! There was
a spider on your cheek!
That's where my face is.
Okay, well-- Ugh!
- [chittering]
- Oh.
That's not good.
No, Ma, I, uh...
I don't think I got
any of them today.
Well, I know you'll
get something soon.
Yeah, Ma, that's, uh...
that's real sweet.
If you change your mind,
the rec center back home
is still looking
for acting coaches.
You can save your money,
and then move back out.
Ma,
I'm not changing my mind.
Thanks, though.
I just hope she knows
how much I loved her.
Who? Gi'gel?
Mm-hmm.
Aw.
She knows, Paul.
She knows.
- Thanks.
- Mm-hmm.
Mo:
Today was tough.
It's like
when everybody tells you
to follow your dreams,
no one tells you how fast
they're running
away from you.
- Is he rehearsing again?
- Mmm. Sounds like it,
but whatever it is,
I hope he gets the role.
Be good for him.
In every story you read,
every-- every biography
is all told from
a point of success.
Uh, I guess they don't
write biographies
about people
who didn't make it.
I'm not complaining.
Complaining's not going to...
help me pay my mom back
or get me that life
that I'm trying to live.
Plus,
complaining's for losers,
and I'm from Philly, man.
I don't lose
at anything, so...
[sigh]
But you know what?
I'm just going
to keep working...
and keep believing.
And we're going to make it.
I truly believe that.
We're going to make it.
You know, guys,
I'm really sorry about--